our journalistic firefighters get down
to the crucial business of investigating
high school children
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez says the world
will end in 12 years and Democrats play
the 2020 game this is the Ben Shapiro
show
oh man there is so much in the news
happening I have so many things to say
about those things just like every day
it's as though I do this for a living
we're gonna get to all the news in just
a second but first let's talk about how
you make your business better well the
best way to make your business better is
hiring correctly and hiring can be
pretty time-consuming you post a job to
several online job boards only to get
tons of the wrong resumes then you have
to sort through all of the resumes just
to find a few people with the right
skills and experience those job sites
that overwhelm you with the wrong
resumes that they're not smart that's
why you should do the smart thing and go
over to zip recruiter comm slash daily
Wire unlike other job sites it recruiter
finds qualified candidates just for you
it's powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and then actively invites
them to apply to your job so you get
qualified candidates fast it is no
wonder that zip recruiter is rated
number one by employers in the United
States this rating comes from hiring
sites on trust pilot with over a
thousand reviews right now my listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at zip
recruit comm slash daily wire if you
love the show show your support for the
show and zip recruiter by going to zip
recruit comm slash daily Wire Dai ly WI
re that zip recruiter comm slash daily
where we use it here at the daily wire
offices zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire zip recruit comm
slash daily wire zip recruiters comm
slash daily wear go check them out
they're fantastic all right so the
latest update from Covington high school
now yesterday on our radio show we
talked to several of the Covington high
school students and I've been speaking
to them ever since and they've been
giving me updates the latest update is
that they had to cancel classes over at
Covington high school because of death
threats because of bomb threats no I am
not kidding they've now had to cancel
school today and they had to cancel
their basketball game which was
scheduled for the next couple days
because of all the violent threats that
are being made over a completely
falsified video that the media pushed
forward so the media over the weekend
pushed forward this videos you'll recall
from yesterday's show they pushed
forward a video suggesting that
Covington high school students
surrounded an elderly Native American
Vietnam veteran and then began berating
him yelling at him obstructing him and
all the rest it turns out that was all a
lie it was not true
the further video shows that what
happened is that there were a bunch of
black Hebrew Israelites cult members who
were yelling racial sexual orientation
slurs at the students the students did
not respond except by chanting their
school chants
at which point Nathan Phillips this
elderly Native American gentleman he
decided to saunter into the middle of
the high school students with some of
his buddies pounding a drum and getting
in the faces of some of the students the
students did not react to that and for
this the students were castigated they
are now receiving death threats they're
receiving bomb threats they have been
doxed I mean I've spoken to a bunch of
the students at this point these are
from my impression good solid kids I see
no evidence that they are racist I see
no evidence that they did anything
egregious or wrong and you're seeing
commentary from folks on the left
suggesting that one kid in particular
Nick Sandman who's the one who you see
in the video standing face to face with
the Native American guy that he was
doing something wrong by smiling so now
a white guy smiling is racist that's how
far we have come so I'm Martin Luther
King Day yesterday people were talking
about how a white kid smiling was racist
because he happened to be wearing a mag
a hat you think maybe we have gone too
far in this country in terms of
polarizing people by way of race it's
pretty astonishing while President Trump
did the right thing yesterday he tweeted
out about Covington Catholic he was he
was watching Tucker Carlson's show
Tucker did a great job of covering this
issue last night on Fox News and Trump
tweeted out looking like Nick Sandman
and Covington Catholic students were
treated unfairly with early judgments
proving out to be false smeared by media
not good but making big comeback new
footage shows that media was wrong about
teens encounter with Native American at
Tucker Carlson that's great I mean I had
recommended to the White House that
President Trump actually tweet at
nick-san men nice hat Nick want to come
to the White House remember Barack Obama
did that with clock boy remember there
was that that Muslim kid in Texas who in
my opinion falsely claims that he'd been
expelled for for building a clock when
in fact he brought in a device that
looked very much like a bomb and the
student and he was briefly investigated
and suspended briefly and then Barack
Obama suggested it was racism in
Islamophobia and then invited him to the
White House it seems to me that if
somebody's been maligned here it's
nick-san man who's been deeply maligned
by all of this
it is really really gross and the media
haven't stopped completely it's amazing
now you're suddenly starting to see the
media think twice about what they've
done here and all the rest and listen
I'm not saying that in the aftermath of
the immediate tape that things were
super clear because they weren't on
Saturday night
came back on right I was I was lucky on
Friday night I was off because it's been
a long day and it was Sabbath so I
didn't see any of this until Saturday
night on Saturday night I got online on
Twitter and I started retweeting various
different opinions on the issue because
I had not made up my mind yet then I saw
the tape and I said this is absurd what
the hell is going on here and that's
where my opinion landed on Saturday
night Sunday morning Monday the media
continued to press forward the case that
these kids are racist so how are they
gonna press forward the case that these
kids are racist well they're gonna bring
on people who weren't even at the event
to talk about how these kids were racist
they brought on a tribal rights attorney
and the MSNBC brought on a tribal rights
attorney who admits in the interview she
was not present when any of this
happened but she saw something racist
that happened why is her opinion any
better than yours or mine or anyone else
who watched the tape it isn't but MSNBC
pushed it anyway maybe a hundred
students who were getting louder and
louder and louder all wearing making it
make America great again hats you you
had walked away prior to that point
happening I personally kind of felt
unsafe you know I could feel the energy
in the air change to surround an
indigenous elder and chant build the
wall kind of exposes that it really has
nothing to do with border security it
seems like it's an issue of race and
white supremacy there is no evidence and
I witnessed something that was very
aggressive and something that was very
frightening okay she she witnessed
something very aggressive and very
frightening are you kidding me
like she says that she she witnessed all
of this stuff there but it didn't happen
it didn't happen right so people were
bringing out this this statement about
about what she had to say as though she
had any sort of real insight in there
she said she was there so I cracked
myself she says she was there but her
accounts is wrong this is tape that
proves that it was wrong so what are we
gonna believe our own lying eyes this
lady the media continued to push this
forward until it became unpossible
anymore at which point some in the media
swiveled and decided to clock other
members of covington high school for
more non racist stuff so the worst
egregious offenders today are the folks
over at the New York Daily News
okay the folks over at the New York
Daily News so over at the New York Daily
News this was the headline yesterday and
still today they've not taken this down
I mean this is libelous material really
like suable this is this is what
their headline says see it Covington
Catholic High students in blackface at
past basketball game and they show a
picture of these kids who are yelling at
an opposing player who's a black kid and
a couple of the kids are completely
covered in black body pains and here is
what the New York Daily News reports
this won't help Kentucky student Nick
Sandman's case a photo said to be
featuring Covington Catholic High School
students clad in black face during a
2015 basketball game made the rounds on
Twitter Monday morning amid last week's
indigenous peoples March controversy
okay the photo depicts several white
students some in blackface shouting an
opposing black player while the photos
origins couldn't be verified the
official Covington Catholic High School
YouTube account published a video last
January boasting its basketball school
spirit and several clips including one
from 2012 showcase attendees chanting in
blackface a mockery of the opposing
players the school took down the video
later on Monday so what what's the story
here was this really a racist incident
okay so first of all number one they are
now citing incidents that are not this
incident about kids who are not this kid
from a time that is not this time number
two were these kids even in blackface
mocking the black player no this was a
black out game it's a black out gate for
people who don't know anything about
high school sports very often in high
school sports they will have games that
are white out games or black out games
or blue out games where both teams wear
a color of the uniform right though one
will wear white one will wear black one
and then they'll reverse or they'll both
wear blue but it'll be white on blue
versus blue on white and then the
students will dress up in the color for
that game so in a blue out game then
everybody will wear blue right and
people paint themselves blue this was a
black out game so some of the kids
painted themselves black were they
mocking black people no of course they
weren't mocking black people there's no
evidence that they were mocking black
people the New York Daily News ran with
it anyway because now they have to
demonstrate that they may have been
wrong about this case but they weren't
wrong in general they are applying the
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez view of politics
it's not important to be factually
correct it's just important to be
morally correct the New York Daily News
which is just a piece of garbage
newspaper they report Sandman the
covington junior donning a Magna cap
tried to dispel reports that he was
mocking Nathan Phillips and other Native
Americans at the end of the indigenous
peoples March as they perform the
American Indian Movement song at the
Lincoln Memorial
salmon's
in a statement I never interacted with
this protester I did not speak to him I
did not make any hand gestures or other
aggressive moves meanwhile Phillip said
I read it I didn't agree with it it
looked like a lynch mob really did they
look like a lynch mob because it seems
to me that you stood there banging and
drumming a guy's face for like 10
minutes and then you left that's it
that's what it looked like to me now
what's amazing is that people are still
taking this guy at his word as I said
yesterday we have this presumption when
it comes to people on the left lying
about things that happen that they're
not actually lying that we have to take
their statements with the greatest
benefit of the doubt possible it's the
same reaction that led people to believe
as President Obama did about Ferguson
Missouri
people don't just make the sort of stuff
up sometimes people make things up of
every race of every race people make
things up yeah in this particular case
the Nathan Nathan Phelps made stuff up
about high-school students the media
swallowed it hook line and sinker and
ran with it and continued some of them
to run with it now Town Hall is
reporting Covington Catholic principal
Bob Roe has closed school on Tuesday in
the wake of the weekend's controversy
the media tore into student Nick Sandman
after a video suggested he had harassed
a Native American veteran when more
footage came out it turned out Sandman
had done nothing wrong
Covington had originally condemned the
actions of his students because
everybody reacts too quickly to
everything right I think that there's a
basic rule in politics that we all need
to apply now is what my mom calls the
count to 10 rule before you react before
you tweet anything before you jump on a
bandwagon count to 10 really just take a
breath and think about maybe whether you
ought to jump on that bandwagon now I'm
not gonna say that I have that I've
never violated that rule of course I
violated that rule I've gotten things
wrong in the past but I think if we all
abide by the count to 10 rule a lot of
pain and friction in our culture would
quickly be avoided Phillips has now
rejected Sandman statement demanding he
write a new one and suggesting that he
and his peers be considered for
expulsion he didn't accept any
responsibility Phillips said that lack
of responsibility I don't accept it and
then Phillips turned down an opportunity
to sit down and meet with a group of
Covington students Cincinnati
restaurants where Jeff Ruby had offered
to host the meeting it's not the right
time Phillip said I might consider it at
some point there has to be certain
assurances in place give and take and
understanding first of all I don't think
the student should sit down with this
guy this guy lied about them why should
they why should they sit down with a
person who slandered them why I wouldn't
what the hell would be the point the
answer is of course there is no point
it's absurd so these kids have nothing
to apologize for
from where I sit I'm not seeing any
evidence they have anything to apologize
for
in a second I'm gonna explain how this
story went viral in the first place
because it's pretty it's pretty amazing
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so does all of this want to make
you put your head under a pillow and
just go to sleep for a while
but then it turns out you can't sleep
maybe it's because your mattress stinks
and what you actually need is a great
mattress from helix sleep helix sleep
has built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete they use the answers
to match your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress
whether you're a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or firm
bed with helix there's no more guessing
and no more confusion just go to helix
sleep calm slash Ben take their two
minutes sleep quiz and they will match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life for couples
helix can even split that mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
they've got a 10 year warranty you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
right now helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders get up to
125 dollars off at helix sleep calm
slash Ben that is helix sleep calm slash
Ben for 125 bucks off your mattress
order again helix sleep calm slash man
my wife and I have a helix sleep
mattress it is spectacular it's really
great my wife and I took that sleep quiz
the mattress came the male inflated
right in front of us because it's made
of foam we put on the bed it's great we
got one for my sister for her wedding as
well it's just terrific go check it out
right now helix sleep calm slash Ben get
125 bucks off alright so how did this
thing go viral in the first place how
did this thing originally go viral well
it turns out that there were a bunch of
fake accounts that were promoting it so
it's hilarious the entire left which has
been consumed with the idea that Russian
bots twisted the 2016 election fell for
a bunch of fake accounts on Twitter
promoting this stuff so according to
cnn.com Twitter suspended in accounts on
Monday afternoon that helped spread a
controversial encounter between a Native
American elder and a group of high
school students wearing make America
great again hats the account claimed to
belong to a California school teacher
its profile photo was not of a school
teacher but of a blogger based in Brazil
Twitter suspended the account after CNN
business asked about it the account with
the username 2020 fight was set up in
December 2016 and appeared to be the
tweet of a woman named Talia living in
California teacher and advocate fighting
for
20:20 since the beginning of the year
the accounts had tweeted on average 130
times a day and had more than 40,000
followers late on Friday the account
posted the minute long video and that
video is viewed 2.5 million times and
then it turns out that there are a bunch
of viral accounts that started promoting
all of this stuff and one indicator of
the 20-25 videos virality multiple news
rooms including some national american
outlets reached out to the user asking
them directly about the video molly
McHugh's an information warfare
researcher who saw the tweet and shared
it herself on Saturday she later
realized a network of anonymous accounts
were working to amplify the video so in
other words for all the talk about how
everybody ought to beware of bots and
confirmation bias everybody is subject
to it and it was obvious in this
particular case now in a second I'm
going to explain to you a little bit
more about the Native American elder at
the center of this controversy because
it turns out this is not his first time
pulling this sort of stunt so the Brian
Saavedra reports over at my site daily
wire quote the Native American man at
the center of the controversy involving
a group of Trump supporting high school
boys from Covington Catholic High School
in Kentucky has a history of claiming
disrespect and racism by students Nathan
Phillips claimed in April 2015 that a
group at Eastern Michigan University
were racist toward him after he
approached them while they were
participating in an American Indian
themed party they had little feathers on
I was just gonna walk by Phillips
claimed a group of them said come on
over here come here
then they started whooping and hollering
I said that wasn't honoring that was
racist then at that time it got really
ugly he claimed the students yelled
racial slurs at him and threw a beer can
at him they said go back to the
reservation you blank Indian he said he
says he called the police by the time
they showed up it was like there's no
party there at all Fox to Detroit asked
what Phillips why he decided to approach
the students why didn't just walk away
Philip said for me to just walk by and
have a blind eye do it something just
didn't allow me to do it well the
alleged incident from 2015 mirrors a lot
of exactly what he was claiming here in
a now-deleted article from ABC 7 Detroit
the Eastern Michigan University said
they were investigating the alleged
incident but residents at the address
where the alleged incident happened told
7 Action News none of them were at
Saturday's party and declined to comment
so again maybe his original allegations
in 2015 were true maybe they weren't but
his allegations now sir
they are not true and they were pushed
by the media anyway and you can tell at
this point it's pretty obvious again
let's give people the benefit of the
doubt to the extent of saying maybe some
people honestly got this wrong Friday
and Saturday if you're still pushing the
debunked story today then there's no way
to give you the benefit of the doubt
right you just can't
there's no way to give you the benefit
of the doubt and what's even more
amazing is folks who are making clear
what their real agenda here is okay
their real agenda here is that they hate
the March for Life okay that's really
what this was about the entire reason
the media covered this is because they
hate the March for Life hate people
wearing Magga hats and they decided that
people wearing Magga hats at the March
for life that was a twofer and if you
were white it was a three-fer that means
that they had to be crazy and racist and
they had to be cooks Alyssa Milano made
this absolutely clear right famous famed
great thinker who shows up a Supreme
Court confirmation hearings wearing like
Handmaid's Tale outfits Alyssa Milano
you know most famous for being in
charmed and then nothing else for the
last 20 years so she tweeted out she
tweeted out yesterday with regard to
these Covington high school kids
something incredible so what she tweeted
out let me find the exact tweet because
it really is pretty astonishing
she said that doo doo doo doo sorry
scrolling through her tweets here she
said here quote let's not forget this
entire event happened because a group of
boys went on a school sanctioned trip to
protest against a woman's right to her
own body and reproductive health care it
is not debatable that bigotry was at
play from the start in other words
everyone at the March for Life all
500,000 people 600,000 people all of
those people were bigots all of them
because they opposed Alyssa Milano on
abortion and that's where we are as a
country
these kids were preemptively bigots
because they happen to be there marching
for the rights of the unborn
because toxic masculinity involves
protecting children who have not yet
been born and let's be real about this
all the blowback that everyone at the
March for Life is getting is about one
thing and one thing only there presents
the March for Life that is all this is
about if this had just been a random
political event if this had just been
nothing to do with Trump nothing to do
with the March for Life if this has just
been comic-con none of this would have
been an issue none of it this is all
about trying to destroy anyone who's
remotely associated with the March for
Life and the media bandwagon jumping on
anyone who was there in order to derive
these these nutso narratives that
they're attempting to push we are now
living in an
of the anti religious bigotry you can
see it right this is it's it's amazing
right it's amazing to see the anti
religious bigotry and by the way you're
starting to see people push even more
false narrative about the Covington kids
like there's a video that is currently
going around that shows supposedly a a
kid shouting to a girl it's not rape if
you enjoyed it it turns out that that
kid doesn't go to Covington high the kid
doesn't go to Covington high in a group
of six hundred thousand people you think
you might be able to spot like one nut
probably but the attempt to smear the
entire March an entire high school and
all these kids it's just it's it's
horrifying it's horrifying and as I say
it is part of a broader anti religious
agenda that extends back into last week
as we saw and even before that hey let's
face it the mainstream left in this
country has moved in an anti religious
direction it used to be that religious
warfare in the country was basically in
turn a scene you know Tom Lehrer who's a
famous comedic songwriter back in the
60s he had he had a funny song called
International Brotherhood week and now
our national Brotherhood weekend in the
middle of the song he starts talking
about religious hatred he says in the
Protestant hate the Catholics and the
Catholics hate the Protestants and the
Hindus hate the Muslims and everybody
hates the Jews right that's sort of
usually how religious warfare works but
we're now living at a time where the
secular left has decided to take on
every one of traditional judeo-christian
values whether it is Karen pence
teaching at a religious school whether
is the Knights of Columbus or whether it
is these kids who are acting out their
Catholic faith by going to the March for
Life rally that's what this is really
about this is about a deep-seated
conflict between folks who cannot stand
the presence of religion in everyday
life and people who are religious that's
all this about and they're finding
they're finding excuses for this sort of
behavior everywhere they're trying to
redefine Christianity to meet their
political needs there's a gun Adam Lance
has a piece today at the Washington Post
in which he suggests that Karen pens for
example who is teaching at a Christian
school that requires kids to abide by
traditional Christian values that they
can't rely on Christianity this is just
pure bigotry masquerading as
Christianity this is the way so many on
the Left view actual traditional
Christianity it's a basket of bigotries
masquerading as a religion and so if we
could just strip away the religious
veneer the bigotry would remain and we
would see all these people for the bad
people they
Karen Pence is actually a bigot she's
not a religious woman according to Adam
lats you know we can't we can't take
that at face value when Karen pen says
she's religious or when these Covington
high school kids say they are religious
because the truth is religion has been
open to interpretation for a very long
time anybody who makes the claim that
certain basic creedal truths of doctrine
are open to interpretation that have not
changed for 2,000 years and I'm not
talking about metaphorical
interpretation of the seven the six days
of creation and the Sabbath and I'm not
talking about the interpretation of
slavery which is not mandated by the
Bible I'm talking about things like do
not do X okay if it says in the Bible do
not do actually know what the Bible
generally means by that do not do X
which means it is a religious truth but
folks on the Left don't want to
acknowledge that they would prefer to
castigate anyone who disagrees with them
as an inherent Center that's as an
inherent bad person that's that's really
where they want to go that really
religion is a cover for bigotry okay in
just a second I want to talk about the
new radicalism inside the Democratic
Party it is moving very very quickly
first let's talk about whether you can
protect yourself so the founders wanted
to enshrine the First Amendment they
want to make sure that you had freedom
of religion freedom of speech freedom of
association and then they recognized the
only way to make sure that you would be
able to retain those things if there was
a second amendment which is why BCM
exists bravo company manufacturing was
started in a garage by a Marine veteran
more than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they're a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company the design engineer and
manufactured life-saving equipment and
assume that each rifle leaving their
shop will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
oversees every components of a BCM rifle
is hand assembled and tested by
Americans to a life-saving standard BCM
feels a moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that will not
fail the user when it's not just a paper
target look I've always said you don't
own a rifle for hunting you don't own a
rifle for sport you own a rifle because
you need it in order to protect yourself
and protect your rights
BCM agrees to learn more about bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
Bravo Company MFG comm that's Bravo
Company MFG comm or check them out at
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA meet
the folks who founded the company
really fantastic people Bravo Company
MFG comm go check them out right now
okay so meanwhile the Democratic Party
is moving leftward radically and leading
that charge is of course the
effervescent Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
right that is the thing that really
matters right now that's the thing is
that Alexandra cosmic Cortes is
effervescent she's she's fantastic and
and they're moving in a radical
direction so example Alexandra Ocasio
quartz has said something that was
neither morally true nor factually true
but demonstrates the catastrophic
thinking that is taken over the
Democratic Party she's speaking
yesterday and she says that Millennials
believe that the world will end in 12
years
okay Nostradamus lay it on us the world
is gonna end in 12 years if we don't
address climate change and your biggest
issue is your your biggest issue is how
are we gonna pay for it and like this is
the war this is our world war two so
much sciencing so much sciencing can she
give us like an exact date can we make a
movie about it you know like there was
2012 and it came out a few years ago
like in 2012 about the end of the world
and Mayan prophecies or something can
she like I think that when she does that
much like the world's gonna end in like
12 years I know first of all I know
someone is speaking science when they
add the word like before their estimate
of a disaster when they say things akin
to when they say something like hey the
world is going to end in like 52 years I
know to take it super seriously because
the like that precedes the 12 years
that's that's really where I know it's
going also I find it hilarious that
Alexandra cosmic order has is making the
claim and the world is going to end in
12 years so we like have to do
everything we can it's just like world
war two like whoa whoa okay so we got to
do everything it's a crisis we gotta do
what like we're worried about how much
money things are gonna cost an out like
who's it gonna care we're all gonna be
dead yo like okay so let's assume that's
true let's assume the world is ending in
12 years first of all nothing you do now
is gonna stop what's gonna happen in 12
years if the climate science really
suggested that in 12 years we're all
gonna be dead that there's gonna be a
giant fireball from the sky that fries
the earth ain't nothing you can do about
it and you're paying higher
taxes ain't gonna solve the problem
either number two if that really is if
it's preventable if Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez believes the global warming is
going to kill us all in 12 years and
what it really requires is us to get
together a crew comprised of Ben Affleck
and Bruce Willis to go on a space
mission to the Sun to stop the Sun from
killing us all in 12 years maybe she
should trade some of her legislative
priorities for all the money necessary
to make this happen so proposal to
congressional Democrats if you believe
that the crisis of humankind is
dependent on your tax rates why don't
you just say how about this how about
this we'll just go for pro-life well ban
all abortions right no more abortions
and for that we will trade the spending
that you want seems like a pretty good
deal
after all we're preserving the future of
humanity here I just love the idea that
she's a pro science human Alexandra
she's a reasonable pro science person
who knows things people she knows things
and that is an astonishing clip and I
had my producers pulled that before I'd
actually listen to the entire thing
word-for-word
it is pretty wonderful that wasn't the
only dumb thing that she decided to say
and again she is now leading this green
New Deal push being praised by the
intelligentsia on the on the left hey
Alexander of cosmic Cortes also says it
is immoral immoral that billionaires
exist so here she was yesterday
explaining not only is the world going
to end in 12 years but it is immoral
that billionaires exist well I have a
solution for the billionaires existing
in 12 years the world warning system
won't matter anymore because everybody
will be dead so I guess that solves the
problem there's no more billionaires I
mean there's no more other people either
but there's that also I'm just wondering
if she thinks it's immoral the
billionaires exist how does she think
that half the globe was raised out of
out of dire extreme poverty in the last
30 years
I saw CNN tweeting this nonsense out
yesterday to I'll explain in just a
second here here's aoc in all of her
eminent wisdom explaining economics we
live in a moral world that allows for
billionaires is that a moral outcome
it's not I don't think it's not it that
necessarily means that all billionaires
are amoral but I do think the system
that allows billionaires to exist
and there are parts of Alabama where
people are still getting ringworm
because they don't have access to public
health is wrong okay so I love that the
system that exists is just unfair you
know I'm not saying billionaires are bad
people okay so these two things cannot
coincide right if you say the
billionaires are not bad people who are
not exploiting people then how do you
rip the system that creates billionaires
but really if you have a free classroom
and the classroom is a free place of
intellectual inquiry and some students
do better than other students and you
say you know what I'm not ripping on the
students who do better because that
would not be right I mean they're good
kids but I'm just ripping on a system
that allows those students to succeed
you can't have it both ways either the
billionaires are exploiters which is why
we should dock them their money or they
haven't done anything wrong in which
case you are just a jealous creep who
wants to steal their money and give it
to somebody else because you think that
you are fairer than a system of free
enterprise I love the idea that you can
sort of destroy the foundational notions
of free enterprise by saying that you
shouldn't be able to make a certain
amount of money and then you can assume
that all of the gains of free enterprise
will remain that it doesn't kill the
entrepreneurial spirit that it doesn't
destroy the ability to create and design
new products America's economy is
dynamic specifically because we have
lots of billionaires seriously Bill
Gates you take away his entire profit
motivation after he makes a million
dollars because a million dollars is
rich right you take away his entire
profit motivation how many people do you
think he hires at Microsoft I think is
gonna work for the public dole ain't
happening and the fact is the
billionaires are the people who create
the jobs for a lot of other people and
they're not creating the jobs because
they're wonderful nice people they're
creating the jobs because they need to
hire people so they can continue making
money the free market system is a way of
turning selfishness into altruism the
free market system means that my desire
for additional profit means that I have
to give you something that you want
CNN tweeted something out like this
yesterday 12,000 billionaires own more
wealth than the bottom 50% of the
world's population
okay so honest to god so there are
people in LA right now who own a lot
more money than I do have they stolen
their money from me did they steal my
money in any way if the answer is no
then you're just being jealous if the
answer is no then you just want to
undermine the greatest system
for the alleviation of poverty in the
history of humanity a system that does
not allow the confiscation of wealth
from other people just because you are
jealous of them okay so we have two big
hits from Alexandre Ocasio Cortez over
the last 24 hours won the world is
ending in 12 years - even though the
world is ending in 12 years what we
really have to worry about is the rich
people who have ensured that poor people
can get out of poverty I'll give you the
third radical silly thing that she said
in just a second first you're gonna have
to go over to Daley wire calm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to Taylor wire Dom when
you do you get the rest of this show
live you got the rest of mandrel clave
in the show live Michael Mosley's show
live in we are slaving away for you we
have two additional hours every day I'm
exhausted look at me two additional
hours every day of content for you
behind the paywall commercial-free when
you subscribe and you can be there alive
and during the commercial breaks for our
radio show you can ask questions
sometimes if I deem you worthy you can
check all that out when you subscribe
plus it's time for our next episode of
the conversation tonight at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
Andrew Clavin will be taking your
questions and answering them live on air
so get ready to have your mind blown by
the wisdom and knowledge you've been
waiting for plus you will get his
baldness curation tips as always this
episode will be free for everyone to
watch on Facebook and YouTube only
subscribers can ask the questions once
again subscribe to get your questions
answered by Andrew Clavin tonight at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific and join the
conversation go check it out right this
very instant also go subscribe a YouTube
and iTunes our last Sunday special
featured Ellen West we have a bunch of
fantastic Sunday specials coming up in
the next few weeks I mean big name great
guests we started doing one yesterday is
just great so you're really going to
enjoy our Sunday special so go check
that out and subscribe leave us a review
it always helps us on places like iTunes
worth noting you are listening to the I
Heart Radio news podcast of the year and
you're just going to put that out there
so the least you can do is subscribe we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so the third stupid thing that
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez said in the last
24 hours
is she called for racial reparations
racial reparations why well why don't we
let her explain economically speaking
and we talked about the issue of say
reparations people think you know people
people think about reparations as
reparations for slavery but really
economically speaking reparations are
for the damage done by the New Deal and
redlining because that is where we saw a
compounding a compounding of the
existing inequity from the legacy of
slavery where we drew red lines around
black communities in the New Deal the
New Deal really I think the people are
sort of cheering lis nobody has any idea
what she's talking about because that
makes no sense what is she even talking
about if you don't say Jim Crow okay but
the New Deal like the thing FDR did I
thought you guys like that yeah aren't
you calling your your environmental
program the green new deal which would
be really bad branding if you think the
New Deal was racist in about redlining
that's real weird okay so but here's the
new democratic platform you're all gonna
die in 12 years steal the billionaire's
money and racial reparations great so
this is the new Democratic Party now the
good news for Republicans is that the
Democratic base at least members of the
primary base seem to be eating all of
this up what that means is that they're
very interested in pushing forward the
race issue particularly that means that
in 2020 the person who has the upper
hand is Kamala Harris the senator from
California after all she has no record
in the Senate except for ripping on
Catholics and lying about Brett
Kavanaugh and she happens to be with
black and a woman so those are the
things that matter in the Democratic
primary she lied about Brett Kavanaugh
she attacked Catholics and she also is
both black and a woman which is
SuperDuper important because things very
important that she is that she's a
racial minority and that she's a woman
because after all stuff so Kamala Harris
announced that she was going to be
running for president and everybody in
the media was very excited and no one
outside the media was very excited
here's Kamala Harris who's chief
qualification for being presidents of
the United States is that she was a
terrible Attorney General in my home
state of California here she is
we've got to reach out to folks we've
got to go where they are understand who
they are we have to listen as much as we
talk and that is certainly what I intend
to do as a as a candidate for the
President of the United States it is my
full intention to travel this country
and to sit in living rooms and to listen
to families and let them express their
concerns and their needs and understand
that when we take on these positions it
is about representing all of the people
of the country Wow
riveting stuff from Kamala Harris her
program is she's going to sit there and
listen to you so if you need a traveling
psychiatrist who can't prescribe drugs
and also is not qualified Kamala Harris
is your lady she's gonna come to your
house knock on your door and listen to
all your problems and then leave and
tell you she solved all your problems
because America is a terrible place
what's amazing is because everybody sort
of knows that Kamala Harris has a
particular advantage when it comes to
the primaries namely the same advantage
that Barack Obama had over Hillary
Clinton in 2008 which is the 30% of the
primary voting base of the Democratic
Party is black and they voted in
solidarity in 2008 a lot of black folks
voted overwhelmingly for Barack Obama in
2008 Kamala Harris has an upper hand
that means that the number one thing
that all of the Democratic candidates
now have to do is racially pander this
is legitimately like first on the
priority list so Joe Biden who wants to
run for president for the 19th time and
happens to be old and white he is going
to now pander as much as he possibly can
to racial minorities suggesting that
Donald Trump is race - the way that
you're going to be able to overcome the
fact that he's an old white man is by
pointing to the other old white man in
the White House and saying that guy's a
racist and I'm standing for you because
he's a racist so here was Joe Biden
doing that routine yesterday we've
learned in the last two years it doesn't
take much to waken hate to bring those
folks out from under the rocks that part
of American society has always been
there will always be there but that's
been legitimized we have to speak out we
have to so when he says all of this you
know it's honestly it's a point
of real annoyance for me the idea that
he's allowed to get away with the great
lie that racism started with President
Trump it's just it's just a lie and it's
the truth is that if you look at the
actual polling data what you will see is
that racism not only did not start with
Trump the rise of racial polarization
did not start with President Trump it
actually started and began to widen
under Barack Obama I'm looking at the
polling data right this minute
take for example race relations by
Gallup poll data just 45% of Americans
were worried about race relations either
a great deal or a fair amount in March
2008 right that was the middle of the
2008 election by March 2015 that number
had risen to 55%
by March 2016 that number was 62% so in
the course of eight years under Barack
Obama the number of Americans who were
worried about race relations either a
great deal or a fair amount had risen 17
points hey but right now it's at 64
percent so it's only risen a couple of
percent since Trump was elected but it
arisen 17 points between when Obama was
elected and when Obama was leaving
office does that suggest that racism in
America is due to Trump or is it
possible that the left constant focus on
racial polarization for political gain
actually had a cost it doesn't matter
Democrats are going to continue to push
forward this nonsense and it's not just
Joe Biden it's also Bernie Sanders so
Bernie Sanders who it's kind of
fascinating Bernie Sanders ran as a kind
of post-racial socialist in 2016 in his
campaign he was asked about racial
issues and it caused some real tension
with folks on town and he see Coates he
said well Bernie Sanders just doesn't
understand racism because Bernie Sanders
keep saying that socialism is a cure for
racism Bernie Sanders his take is
basically that under socialism everybody
is viewed equally and so if we
redistribute the wealth then racism will
automatically go away and folks like
Donaghy C coats were saying well that's
pretty short-sighted well now Bernie
Sanders because he wants to run again
feels the need to reach out and win more
minority votes if he wants to head off
people like Camille Harris so now he's
going to go full-bore on the Trump is a
racist train even though over the last
couple of years he's been kind of dicey
about just calling Trump a racist now
this is going to be the the coin of the
realm the entry cost for becoming a
Democratic presidential candidate is
going to be calling President Trump a
racist today we talked about justice and
today we talk about racism and I must
tell you
it gives me no pleasure to tell you that
we now have a President of the United
States who is a racist okay so this is
what we are going to hear from now until
election time from every Democrat is how
racist President Trump is now as I've
said before I'm not gonna defend every
statement the President Trump is made
particularly not about charlottesville
but if you want to call President Trump
a racist you're gonna need to do a
little bit better then I changed my mind
in the last five minutes when I was
running for a president it's pretty
amazing
okay so time for a quick update on the
government shutdown remember that things
going on remember as this government
shutdown and like a bunch of people
aren't getting paid it turns out all you
have to do is misdirect to a bunch of
high school students and then no more
and then no one cares about the
government shutdown anymore pretty
amazing oh quick note breaking poll and
you just point this out there's a poll
about Alexander Ocasio cortes whose
myriad stupidities we just pointed out a
new poll shows that 74 percent of
Democrats would consider voting for
Ocasio cortes if she were old enough to
run for president including 17% who
would definitely vote for her she top
Senator Chuck Schumer and favorability
among Democrats and overall nearly
rivals Speaker Nancy Pelosi really
incredible that's how radical the
Democrats have moved anyway back to the
government shutdown so the government
shutdown continues apace Democrats have
completely ignored then they've
completely ignored president Trump's
offer and they're doing so out of pure
political expediency a democratic
representatives sort of acknowledged
that yesterday his name is Tom
Malinowski he is from New Jersey and he
says that the most painful concession
for him to make would be the wall and he
says that if we're gonna get the wall
then we need to comprehend that we need
amnesty I'm only gonna trade the wall
for amnesty remember there's already
border fencing on large parts of our
nation's southern border but the wall is
what really has him really has him upset
painful concession for me to make as a
Democrat who ran against this kind of
stupidity and fear would be money for a
border wall if you want to if you want
me to consider something like that I
need to see comprehensive immigration
reform I need to see an end to the
cruelties of the last two years if
President Trump wants border security on
his terms I've got to see America
as a welcoming country of immigrants and
refugees okay so if this is the new
democratic agenda is border wall bad
except for the current border fencing
that's in place that border fencing is
good now how is this all going to play
out well yesterday Aviation unions were
coming out and explaining that if this
shutdown continues very much longer
you're going to see massive numbers of
flights canceled because there are just
too many people who are dependent on
federal government largesse and the TSA
for their flights here is one of the
heads of one of the aviation unions is
Sarah Nelson international president of
the Association of flight attendants
saying federal workers being shut down
not getting paid it's going to lead to a
massive private strike that is going to
shut down the airline industry if these
workers can't do their job I can't do
mine and you these federal workers
cannot cash thank-yous we can't
they've got stressors on their family
they can't even put a tank of gas in
their car to get to work and as this
starts to crumble and unravel we're
going to see mass flight cancellations
we're going to see a system that
completely unravels and follows apart we
will not have private jets taking off to
get people to the Superbowl no one will
be able to get to Atlanta this is going
to have a massive economic impact so
then the question is going to be who
gets blamed for all of this now here's
the truth the airline industry never
should have been federalized the airline
industry never should have been
federalized it all should have been done
privately there's no reason the taxpayer
should be footing the bill for the
airline industry it would not have been
that difficult for air traffic
controllers to be privately hired by a
consortium of flight companies have each
company to its own security would
actually be a selling point whose
security was best but because we
federalize everything it's now become a
federal issue with that said if flights
start getting shut down there's gonna be
additional pressure to stop the
government shut down and that's why
Republicans President Trump they need to
be laying the groundwork right this very
minute for saying the Democrats are
being completely unreasonable every
tweet Trump sends should be on how
unreasonable Democrats are being he
should be at the border right now
pointing to open spaces in the border
where people are walking across and
saying all they have to do is fund this
this five-feet right here and we can end
this government shutdown but they hate
me so much they won't do it this is time
for a full-court press by Republicans
because Democrats simply don't care they
think they can wait around to let the
media do their bidding for them and
they're right the media will do their
for them the media are not going to ask
serious questions of Democrats the media
are not going to ask guys 5.7 billion
dollars is like 12 hours of federal
funding 12 hours of it so why don't you
just give over the money the media won't
ask those questions so Trump is gonna
have to force the issue he absolutely
should force the issue Republicans
should force the issue because this is
no longer a fight between Democrats and
Republicans it is a fight between
Republicans and the media and believe it
or not that's a fight that President
Trump can win all he has to do is engage
in that fight right now he has
disengaged which is kind of shocking to
me and the president needs to be
personally out there on the stump
beating the war drums and that's true
for everybody on the Republican side of
the aisle right they all need to be out
there explaining why this is a problem
and why all they would have to do is get
5 cents a nickel out of the cushions in
order to pay for this thing because when
the bleep really hits the fan here when
the flights start getting canceled the
American people are going to turn on
somebody Republicans should ensure that
it is not them all right time for a
couple of things I like and then some
things that I hate so things that I like
today there's a book that I just read I
love sports books so I'm a big sports
fan and there's there was a league for a
little while in the 1980s called the
USFL it was supposed to rival the NFL
and it was supposed to be a spring
league so it wasn't really a direct
competitor to the NFL - the NFL plays
and fall in winter the USFL was supposed
to take place in spring and very early
on it was a big success story they'd
started to pick up some real players
like Steve Young played in the USFL
Herschel Walker played in the USFL Jim
Kelly got his start in the USFL
and the league was actually not bad a
bunch of those players ended up in the
NFL in the USFL shut down the the book
is really a fun read it also has a lot
about President Trump because President
Trump was eight was a team owner in the
USFL and President Trump was was at that
time Donald Trump was was very involved
in sort of the demise of the USFL so the
book is a lot about that and it gives
you a window into how President Trump
negotiates which is to say he sort of
sets a goal and then doesn't necessarily
know how to get there and it's a real
problem for him so it's a window of
insight is it biased I'm sure but the
book itself is really amusing and fun
okay meanwhile this Evan would put this
in things I would probably put this in
things I hate so let's do some things I
hate
okay so let's talk about what was
nominated for Best Picture this year so
the Oscar nominations are finally out
one of the things I love about the fact
that the Oscar nominations have been
brought in to eight or ten films now in
Best Picture category is it was supposed
to include films people had seen out of
the films that people out of all let's
see how many films were nominate
out of the eight films that have been
put up for Best Picture three are films
that people have seen Black Panther
which is first of all it's absurd the
Black Panther is nominated for Best
Picture I like I like the picture just
fine it was fine it is insane that it
was nominated it was not even like the
third best comic book movie of the year
and so the spider-verse was clearly the
best comic book movie and then I would
say that Avengers infinity war is a
better movie than Black Panther and
here's for the controversial part about
Aquaman was a better movie than Black
Panther I just didn't but I thought it
was okay I thought was fine it was you
know a Marvel movie with a bad ending
but and it really had one compelling
character and Cole monger but it's
nominated for Best Picture all right
fine is it silly first comic book movie
to be nominated for Best Picture since I
believe The Dark Knight
which shows you a decline in quality to
the Dark Knight is an all-time great
flick Black Panther will be forgotten
seven minutes after this Best Picture
Oscars but the other ones hadn't been
nominated that made some money Bohemian
Rhapsody made some money by a bunch of
boomers and Gen Xers who still remember
we are the champions and then a star is
born made some money because it had
Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
none of those three are gonna win Best
Picture and ones that are really up for
Best Picture our black clansmen which is
Spike Lee's film which I've watched and
it's mediocre and ain't that great Spike
Lee hasn't produced a good movie since
do the right thing
the favorite which is about lesbian
affairs in 19th century England so good
times and then there's green book which
is everybody's sort of favorite which is
which means it won't win right it's now
and it's now in the front-runner
position which means there will be a
backlash before the Oscars and then it
won't win Green book is about a mob
stand Italian mobster who is low level
in model level enforcer who's driving a
black a guy through the South in the
1960s so it's about how America is
intolerant but tolerant we love each
other but we're intolerant you've heard
this too it's it's Driving Miss Daisy
basically except in Reverse right so
it's
it's got some problems Roma I watched
the first seven minutes and I was almost
comatose it is one of the most boring
slow moves I've ever seen the last 20
minutes of it are good but that does not
justify nine-hour running time and
advice which is just a hit piece on dick
cheney's so well done Hollywood
once again nominating a bunch of movies
that either no one has seen or are not
very good and ignoring the only great
picture of the year there there are two
okay so a quiet place was a good picture
this year and then there was a great
picture this year the death of Stalin
which received zero nominations and is
by far the best picture of the year I
raved it at the time it is the best
picture of the year got completely shut
out cuz it says Stalin is bad America is
bad very good for the Oscars Sahlin is
bad not so much okay and then get to the
other nominations you got actress in a
supporting role got Amy Adams in Vice
because she's nominated for whatever she
does Marina de tavera in Romo Regina
King in if Beale Street could talk which
I'm surprised wasn't nominated for Best
Picture I've heard it's quite good and
then Emma Stone and Rachel vice in the
favorite them both of whom are playing
you know the lesbian would be lovers of
the Queen and then you've got you know
actors in a supporting role again all of
them are from movies that nobody has
actually ever seen and and there's no
host this year which is really exciting
right we could have had Kevin Hart who's
at least amusing but no we're not gonna
do that instead we have to make sure
that no one is offended by his comments
that Kevin Hart made ten years ago so
well done Oscars you've done it again
excellent excellent job okay final thing
that I hate for today so I do have to
discuss a comment by Lady gaga
so Lady gaga we talked about this on
yesterday's radio show which is why you
should subscribe but Lady Gaga made a
comment at wonderful content in one of
her concerts about how Mike Pence is a
terrible representative of Christianity
which makes sense because when I think
of people who are great representatives
of Christianity I usually think about
the lady
who warbled the song telephone that's
that's usually who I think about I think
Jesus Mary Joseph the Pope Martin Luther
Lady gaga
in my pantheon of famous Christians
here's Lady Gaga ripping into Mike Pence
for not being sufficiently Christian
[Applause]
so I love the Christianity in our
secular pagan world has been boiled down
to make other people feel good now if
you read the New Testament Jesus wasn't
famous for the making of the people feel
good that what that wasn't this thing
right Jesus was quite harsh with people
you know and when he when he talked to
people who when he when he did the whole
you know people in glass houses
shouldn't throw stones and if the the
splinter in your eye and the log in your
eye that that whole thing that was
followed by going sin no more right so
the idea was you're not supposed to sin
sin is bad don't do it but apparently
the new message of Christianity is the
message of Lady gaga which is do
whatever you want and it's my job to
massage her shoulders that is not what
Christianity is about it's not what you
do Christian religion is about it's not
what morality is about boiling down
Christianity to a pagan acceptance of
bad behavior is pretty much the religion
we deserve you're given today's day and
age as I've said before I really believe
I mean in my new book I talk about this
I actually believe that Lady Gaga's Born
This Way is the single best expression
of the modern mentality when it comes to
morality that has been written and I
think it is deeply immoral in pagan and
the idea that you have a natural drive
to do something therefore God made you
this way
therefore you should probably go and do
it that is precisely the opposite of
traditional religion which suggests that
he drive to do something does not
justify you actually doing that thing
and there's a there's a line in the
movie the African Queen which is a great
movie from the 1950s in which Katherine
Hepburn who is a religious woman says to
another character nature mr. Allnut is
something we are put on earth to
overcome and there's something about
that in religion Lady gaga nature is
something to surrender to and if you
don't surrender to it then you are not
being Christian you know when you go
back and you look at the story of Adam
and Eve one of the questions that is
asked is why is it that what the snake
says is so seductive to Eve and
metaphorically the whole the whole story
in my opinion and in my opinion many
religious scholars is metaphorical not
literal in any case the story is deeply
important
from a psychological perspective so Adam
and Eve are told by God don't eat this
particular Apple from this particular
tree or don't eat this piece of fruit
from this particular tree and the snake
then goes to Eve and says you know God's
kind of lying to you like everything's
gonna be okay you eat from that Apple
looks pretty good it'll be fine
wood gut and here's the actual message
of what the snake is saying when you go
back and look at the text he's saying
would God have made that Apple and make
you have a desire for that Apple if he
didn't mean for you to eat that Apple
so who you gonna believe God or what God
actually created for you if God created
the desire then he wanted you to fulfill
the desire because he created you and he
said okay that's kind of convincing and
she goes and eats the Apple and that's
when God says no when I tell you not to
do something I tell you not to do it
because it turns out that self-control
is one half of becoming a better person
the other half is directing your
self-control at the proper object but
according to our modern society if you
have a desire for something that is in
and of itself a justification of action
along the lines of that desire that
isn't deeply anti-christian message so
I'm not gonna take tips on Christianity
from Lady gaga just not gonna do it
because it's absurd already we will be
back here later with a lot more go
subscribe so you get the other two hours
of the show later this afternoon we're
slaving away for you people if not then
we'll catch you tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua ov era production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19